tarah was hiking up a mountain she
started her hike at an elevation of
1,200 meters and ascended at a constant
rate after four hours she reached an
elevation of 1,700 meters let Y
represent Terra's elevation in meters
after X hours and they asked us this is
from a exercise on Khan Academy says
complete the equation for the
relationship between the elevation and
the number of hours and if you're on
Khan Academy you would type it in but we
could do it by hand so pause this video
and work out work it out on some paper
and let's see if we get to the same
place all right now let's do this
together so first of all they tell us
that she's ascending at a constant rate
so that's a pretty good indication that
we are we could describe her elevation
based on the number of hours she travels
with a linear equation and we could even
figure out that constant rate it says
that she goes from 1200 meters to 1700
meters in 4 hours so we could say her
rate is going to be her change in
elevation over a change in time so her
change in elevation is 1700 meters minus
1200 meters and she does this over 4
hours over her change in time is 4 hours
so her constant rate in the numerator
here 1700 minus 1200 is 500 meters she's
able to go up 500 meters in 4 hours if
we divide 500 divided if we divide 500
by 4
this is 125 meters per hour and so we
could use this now to think about what
our equation would be our elevation Y
would be equal to well where is she
starting well it's starting at 1200
meters so she's starting at 1200 meters
and then to that we're going to add how
much she climbs based on how many hours
she's traveled so it's going to be this
rate 125 meters per hour times the
number of hours she has been hiking so
the number of hours is x times X so this
right over here is an equation for the
relationship between the elevation and
number of hours another way you could
have thought about it you could have
said okay this is going to be a linear
equation because she's ascending at a
constant rate you could say the
slope-intercept form for a linear
equation is y is equal to MX plus B
where B is your y-intercept what is the
value of y when X is equal to 0 and you
say all right when X is equal to 0 she's
at an elevation of 1,200 and then M is
our slope so that's the rate at which
our elevation is increasing and that's
what we calculated right over here our
slope is 125 meters per hour so notice
these are equivalent I've just have
these two terms or swapped so we could
either write Y is equal to 1200 plus 125
X or you could write it the other way
around
you could write 125 X plus 1200 they are
equivalent